after a break of seven weeks taarak is
pulling in his Nets again today he's
been in waters he's never fished before
since the ceasefire Gaza's fishermen
have been allowed up to six nautical
miles off the coast it's a rare
concession by Israel but Tareq and many
colleagues are skeptical Halliwell it's
good but it's also not good we want the
sea to be opened up so we can move
freely but it isn't despite the war
we've been through the many dead and the
destruction we wanted the right to fish
up to 12 miles out that's what the
resistance and our government were
demanding until recently the fishing
zone was just three miles the Israeli
Navy kept careful watch the area was
completely over fished making catches
small and pushing fish prices up too
high for most gazans today's catch
includes kilos of crabs they'll fetch
around one euro per kilo not a bad day
for the fishermen but still they can
barely make ends meet fuel for example
is expensive they're far from satisfied
we thought a long-term ceasefire would
bring a better solution not just the six
miles that's not enough the Israelis
hardly gave ground we had six miles in
2012 we haven't really gained anything
the creation of a proper port in Gaza
was another key demand but talks on that
have been put off till next month the
fish market is packed signs of some
normality returning but many here have
lost everything ISA mollywhop for
example he says he's relatively lucky to
have a roof over his head even if his
home no longer has any walls he hopes
that after the war Israel will finally
allow building materials into Gaza for
the first time in seven years what we
need is real change but we don't see it
we're sitting in our house eating off
plastic plates because we don't have any
crockery left
Haven witness we can't bake our own
bread anymore the Prophet life is really
difficult because we don't have the most
basic things anymore it is a cyber
didn't depend on of it looking for work
liar Gaza's population hopes the
ceasefire will hold but it will take
much more than that for life in the
territory to become anything like normal